le terme il est en sexologue au CHU
Saint-Pierre et porte-parole
interfederale de la lutte contre le
covid-19
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous à
en direct sur RT France en tant que
infectiologues quel regard vous portez
d'abord sur les manifestations du jour à
Bruxelles
je pense que
la population un peu partout dans le
monde
on a un petit peu marre de cette
situation qui dure depuis un an et demi
que je comprends bien
et en plus
pour
les événements
alors effectivement les autorités sont
basés sur le rapport de son appel de
relativement simple bien connu
et
bien sûr
au niveau de la
Belgique aujourd'hui
avec 76 % de la population totale
vacciné 86 % pour les plus de 18 ans et
les populations fragiles et comme les
plus de 65 ans sont vaccinés à 92 % ce
qui se passe c'est que une partie des
groupes n'est pas vacciné la population
est hétérogène à Bruxelles et que
d'autre part d'une partie des personnes
ont besoin d'une troisième et recevoir
les personnes de plus de 65 ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est eux qui sont prises
dans toute l'Europe de l'Ouest
s'éteindre dans les semaines qui
viennent les mesures sont différents
mais je pense qu'il me signer un peu de
semaine près on aura la même action et
j'espère que tu actives Man pour la
mi-décembre l'Europe de l'Ouest à
retrouver un climat épidémiologique plus
plus calme si pas parfait bien sûr
de la couverture vaccinale au niveau
européen
on se dit aussi que les cas grave
c'est une réalité
ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter sur la
situation des des hôpitaux
niveau des hôpitaux le problème c'est
qu'ils ne sont plus dans le même et demi
tous les pays connaissent la section du
personnel hospitalier qui est usé qui
est fatigué et déprimé la plupart les
hôpitaux 15h30 pour 100 heures personnel
indisponible c'est qui condamne un
certain nombre de VI le Gros du problème
n'est plus dans cette diminution de la
capacité des hôpitaux que dans leur
charge nous avons 630 ans il s'occupait
sur les 2 million de la moitié de ce
qu'on avait précédente et le personnel
le plus
c'est de ne pas pouvoir suivre dans les
soins non covit puisque nous sommes en
pleine saison hivernale on a toutes les
infection pulmonaire classic on a le
retard à rattraper sur les interventions
chirurgicales à cause des autres vagues
et il est clair que c'est parti
pour les autres pathologies
aujourd'hui
en Europe
[Musique]
mettre le covid-19